okay so um yeah Stosh couldn't be here
so I'm giving his talk for those who
don't know as stash and I are the two
most last-minute people in the entire
world so I hope it will go well anyway
he's he prepared all the slides and I
never heard about this work until a few
days ago that said feel free to ask any
questions I'll do my best to answer as
best as I can ok so wait didn't say I
guess the title is written here to a
three-party secure computation of orem
ok this is stashes presentation plan I
just wanted to write on the board how I
view the entire talk it will make it
easier for me to skip slides depending
on time etc so here is like a summary of
the entire talk I'll of course explain
what everything is so in prior work we
know the following we know that from MPC
for circuits + RM we can get a CRM
that's what I'll define that's the main
point in the stock secure computation of
RM and this is a very useful primitive
for many things including and the fact
that it gives you MPC for RAM program as
opposed to for circuits which you can
think of as MPC for big data ok so i'll
define these things but this is sort of
the reason this primitive is important
and this MPC for big data we have very
very big data and so it's very important
to make it as practically efficient as
possible so what is that in this work so
all previous works that focused on
practical efficiency I did this part via
secure two-party computation this NPC
was two-party computation and there's
implementations and things this work
does it for three party computation 3pc
for SCORM
and the point is is a much more
efficient or practically efficient then
at least the current known to pc 4 RM
okay so so that's it that's what the
talk is about so you know I'll spend
time defining what this is and how this
generic transformation works which we
already knew but then i'll try to see
how much time i have to describe the
details of how they implement this
transformation with a three-party
computation in a very efficient way it's
with a specific orem which is the tree
RM of sheer dao so i'll also describe
how that works and what how why does the
3pc give them much more efficiency at
least practically speaking yes
everything is honest but curious sorry
yes everything is honest but curious and
in two-party computation I'll talk about
it again this is just a summary of
everything in two-party computation one
can be corrupted in three particular
pretation also only one can be corrupted
so dishonest majority makes life better
and then they have a lot of specific
optimization okay that's the overview
good one stops
good news no it's honest but curious um
I mean maybe it could be improved okay
so but in order to understand all of
this we need to go through all of these
things and placed in general good okay
so i'll start by defining this secure
computation or am primitive which they
isolate from all these works that prove
this implies this they isolate this
secure computation forum primitive which
is a very simple functionality you can
just think of it as follows it's like an
ideal functionality where the input is a
shared data it's not actually depicted
here clearly the input so there n
parties there's some data or you can
think of it as an array the array D is
shared among all the parties and some
index X is also shared as well in
between all the parties these secret
chairs are an input and the output is
new secret shares of the value of the
array at location X okay so this is the
functionality we can think about the
input and the output the truth is
there's also of course in orem there's
both reading and writing if you also
want to write then the input also
includes a secret chair of a value V
that you want to write to location d of
x and the output will be also a new
updated sharing of the database be
modified such that in location X it now
has the value V okay however we will
ignore the writing in the writing in the
stock just for simplicity so I'll only
focus on reading so as if it's always
just reading although everything could
be updated for reading and writing okay
good so if we ignore the writing it's
the easy way to describe the
functionalities just as CRM is a secure
computation and the normal sense of the
functionality that starts from input
sharing of the index and output is
sharing of D and location X okay alright
so let's compare it to a standard or m
and also not just compare also want to
remind you
standard or amis so our I'm oblivious
ROM which was originally introduced by
God reckon Ostrovsky is the following
its thinks of a client and a server
they're also models with multiple
servers but there's a client that from
which there's no security at all so in
the orem setting the client is like the
owner of the data is writing into some
untrusted storage and so we need to hide
the data and the location from the
server but nothing is hidden from the
client okay here insecure computation of
RM there is no client who knows
everything there secrecy among against
all parties ok and in particular no
coalition so they're up to t corrupted
parties no coalition of tea or less
parties knows anything about either the
data on the index ok so it's like we
need to add security for the client side
good ok this is a one loop this is ok
why do we care about scrm this is one
application which stash gives me the
blessing to skip skip so it's you know
it's it's this three dots here I'm going
to skip it let me talk about the main
application and which also i will not go
into details because as i said we will
focus on the first error rather than on
the second error but just to give you
the application one application of
secure computation of the Orang
primitive is that it allows you to do
secure computation of ram programs ok as
opposed to secure computation of circuit
okay and basically the way you do it so
so a ram program random access program
look something like this and you start
you so each instruction works on some
small number of data items and that's
something to them and we can do that
part with normal MPC or to PC or
whatever on this small instruction by
instruction rather than doing MPC on the
whole program we do NPC on instruction
by instruction and when the instruction
wants to read or write from memory we
use their own primitive so that the
access patterns don't reveal anything ok
and the point of all of this is that it
allows
sub linear computation secure
computation because you don't have to
attach the entire data everything here
the input can be our you know log size
and the RM over here this poly log so
everything is poly log x the running
time of the RAM program and not linear
in the database size and that's very
important for MPC on big data good so
that's this application okay so what we
want to show now yeah any questions so
far what we want to show now so going
back to my overview of everything we
want to show how to build scrm from
general MPC for circuits in orem and
i'll show the generic construction which
was known before and then i'll talk
about the what's new in this work yeah
what's important yeah but it will be
because ok I guess I didn't say how it's
yes yes secure computation of frm it
gets as input that's how we define it
gets as input the sharing of DNX and
gives you a sharing of D and location X
this should be you know proportional to
the size of X and only poly long in the
size of the data ok right because
sharing or if has to be some kind of
local update as a shadow tea or
something yeah but that's not so hard
because think of it as as you know it's
like really a ram program when you like
break it down to some like CPU operation
and then write this value into memory or
read this value for memory those
operations are all small right like when
you access some value and you change it
you don't touch the entire data if there
was no security because you have to go
beyond this you know but sharing of D
was there already I just need to up if I
am if I'm reading I don't need to redo
anything with it and that sort of the
abstraction will use in the top but even
if I'm writing I'm only updating one
chair so it's possible and I'll show
next how to achieve it so you will see
how to do I'll show next how to achieve
this funk
nality securely in sub linear and good
time from from general MPC on small
circuit ok and the orem primitive ok
good so this is it that so that's a
generic construction so let's think so
let's remember for a minute what Oh Rama
is not secure from petition of orem just
standard or am so in orem basically you
have a server that holds that so the
server is the untrusted storage he holds
the data which is encrypted with some
secret mmk i guess it stands for master
key it's encrypted with some secret that
the client has and the client is thought
of as the owner of the data he has the
secret to decrypt everything and he has
a location X that he wants to read ok
and in the NorAm did they perform some
interaction and the client gets DN
location X the server gets re encryption
of the data so the data is rhian cryptid
so that it can be used again next time
and the access patterns won't reveal
anything okay like if the client wants
to access the same X again it won't
touch exactly the same points again and
this is important as if gani ask that
this rien krypton doesn't like take the
whole data and you know decrypt it and
Riaan cryptid it has to be sublinear and
that's the whole point of orem primitive
ok good so that's all ramen we want to
achieve it securely but so so here the
client knows X knows the secret key will
learn DX will learn everything when you
clear and can also learn other
information about D and this is what we
want to avoid okay so yeah I said that
so one simple idea is the following
instead of having so that the problem
was that the clients knows the key and
the input and everything instead let's
split the client into two parts ok and
we will secret chair both the secret key
that encrypts the data and X is the
remember the location that the client
wants to access in this command will
secret Jared among the two clients and
then okay and so the clients will
together using a regular 2pc any 2pc
protocol yeah whatever you want we'll
talk to each other to emulate the one
client from the previous slide and the
key point is this to pc has small inputs
the secret key in the location it's of
size log so it doesn't matter look we
don't care about the linear overhead is
fine because the circuit is small here
that's the main point okay so they will
talk you they will know what to discuss
with the server they're just emulating
the one client from last time and the
output will be instead of D of X a
secret sharing of D of X okay that's the
idea and now we can put you know the
first client as one party and the second
client plus the server we can put as
another party together and you can see
that privacy's maintain because this got
the lefty guy p1 has the secret key
share and the index share okay so it
doesn't tell them anything and the right
guy has another share of the secret key
in another share of X and then the
encryption of the data so this doesn't
reveal anything and here so we managed
to apply take any are many 2pc put them
together and get this and so so the or
ramen multi-party computation or secure
compression gives us SCORM okay so this
is how we achieve this functionality
generically
okay good okay so that's it for the
theoretical generic part but now we
really want to achieve everything super
super super efficiently because the idea
is we will work on very large data
that's the whole point and so what we
want is we want to use not generic
components not generic orem but some
kind of orem where the client is secure
computation friendly that's of course
not a formal definition but where the
client can be split into two in a way
that can be very very efficiently you
can apply secure computation to its
operations without much overhead okay so
that's the goal so these are so far only
talked about generic these are an
dungeoneering this is specific
optimizations that we're done to achieve
achieve better to achieve this with as
best security as possible sorry
efficiency as possible so the first two
were in a joint paper with Mariana and
Vlad and Corel cuts and valise where we
did two optimizations one using for the
underlying orem primitive using gold
roth ostrovsky for the two-party
computation using yow but we didn't just
apply pure yow we try to apply on the
smallest possible things and then we had
another primitive there that required
some ddh assumption and some
exponentiation and we had another
instantiation with them using a tree or
am protocol of Sheba and Yau without any
public key operations and then more
recently there is a work but yeah one
get out I guess at a be a Tulane so I
think those are the only people in the
audience from these works that they took
the original tree or I'm of she at all
and tested it the various modifications
with the purpose of making the circuit
as small as possible and making it as
efficient as possible with two-party
computation and indeed the circuit
became much smaller okay so
this I guess was the best known
previously but this is still for I guess
this is a million records you still need
4.6 million gates and even though secure
computation and Yau garble computation
is getting much faster still this is per
each orem access so this is still a lot
of work to do okay and the goal is to
improve that good so the idea to improve
that as well maybe sorry maybe instead
of having two parties will have three
parties okay the generic part is obvious
you can do as many parties as you want
but maybe moving from to party to three
party can make our efficiency much
better and indeed why would we believe
that well first of all we know that if
you have honest majority will assume
these three parties that most one is
corrupted we know that if you have
honest majority things become much
easier and in particular one example is
if you have three parties you can
simulate any protocol for two parties
with correlated randomness because the
third party could give them the
correlated randomness so just as an
example this is an example both to
demonstrate how three parties can be
much much faster than two parties for
simple primitive but also it's used
actually in the protocol in various
places so let's think about oblivious
transfer okay you all know it so party p
1 has m0 and m1 well when how much time
do I have we'll go oh good okay so party
one has m0 and m1 party to as a bit B
and he wants to get mb that's oblivious
transfer and we know that any no matter
how you try to optimize any to party
protocol will need some sort of PK
public key crypto exponentiation and
such the formal statement is based on in
polio to rubbish but they're so the two
party protocols are less efficient
however for three parties we can just do
everything very very simply as follows
using a old trick of beavers of OT with
pre-computation which works as follows
so you can think of it as giving
correlated randomness so P 3 will give
p1 and p2 this correlated randomness
which is just a
and emoti as you see p 3 gives p1 some
random z0 z1 and gives p to some random
bitsy and ZC so it's as if they did OT
on random input and now when the real
inputs come they just spit who needs to
send this XOR and py needs to send those
to X ores and then p 2 needs to do one
more XO to recover the message and we'll
get MC and there's a proof here that it
works but it's very easy you can just
think about it later and see but the
point is this is much much much faster
and in fact doesn't require any crypto I
mean there will be at the end of the day
crypto symmetric crypto just with you
know send stuff over on the channel etc
but it's much faster than doing OT with
two parties I mean this is very similar
to out the extension right with the
third party that's that's what they do
and all the extensions right they do
this precomputed of T's also what is the
extension only uses two parties we go to
the third point yeah okay so i don't
know that so they have experimental
results you can suggest that they try
with only two parties i don't know but i
guess you know i'll tell you what the
answer I think is I don't quite know but
they compare themselves to the two-party
implementations which I assume use the
best you know this one get out 14 I
assume use the best possible available
out the extension is the button making
these the government circles ya know not
all T this is just an example the three
parties are better than to the battle
mech is the garbled circuit not the OT
and yeah we will see that but this this
is also used as part of the of the
protocol to achieve this in a better way
ya know the battle mask is definitely
the garbled circuit okay so now the
question is is so this is kind of we
downgraded the security in order to
achieve better efficiency right so is it
better well I mean I don't know imagine
basically you can imagine this you have
two systems one system needs only two
servers that you assume at most one of
them is corrupted and each query takes a
10 second
this is roughly based on their
experimental results really it's just
the start system needs three servers
that you're so only one is corrupted so
you know it's clearly worse
security-wise but each query takes only
a hundred milliseconds if you could do
that is it worth it yeah system to is
worth security-wise because you when you
have three servers you have redundancy
so if one of the servers dies you can
still recover the data from the other
two where the system 11 of the silver
guys your data is lost you are right
okay so you're saying maybe it's not
even a downgrade yeah but you know
viewing it in the honest but curious
regime which is this all talk is about I
guess maybe it is worse because you need
to add another one yeah maybe it's
better in any case okay that that would
be good for the top requiring the pre
quad redundancy required okay you're one
of the others of the two servers then
adding another one is different it bad
security was yes I guess it depends on
your perspective I mean so so stashes
conclusion is that it's not clear which
one is better but it seems hear the
conclusion is that stashes work is
better which is great okay so so let's
so now we will go into seeing how what
we can achieve with a three parties okay
so this is the result it's a little
dense basically this the stated where is
my yeah stated asymptotically what they
achieve is 3pc three-party computation
for a CRM there's some target cost is
the overhead is log cube of the size of
the data okay and this is the same
asymptotic bounds as this one guitar
that achieved with to party and
asymptotically it's worse than now you
can do better than long cube somatically
the point is because both of these
things use the tree or ram which is not
the best orem asymptotically but it is
the best or ram as far as we know for
practical implementations for a
multi-party computation because the
operations are very amenable to secure
computation so asymptotically there is
no gain but in practice there's
much again seem to be much better
efficiency so add a report something
like between 4.6 million 213 million
gates for this many records I guess
between a million and a trillion records
you need this many gate okay and they
you know needing OTS they need yeah I
guess even for the OT extension you need
some public key operations here although
I agree it's not the bottleneck so here
so whereas here so stashes work also has
the garbled circuit and it's the
bottleneck you know it's seventy percent
of the CPU cost but the size of the
circuits is much much smaller okay so
for this it's 69 k 2 233 k gates yes
Queenie Steve oh gee yes you so you can
do lock the right yeah so this is so so
this is one of the open problems at the
end is can we utilize so that one that
one has a PRF in it which seems a little
harder so one of the open problems is
can we that the slash suggest in the
last slide which I hope we get to is can
we do something that's better both
asymptotically and can we utilize it to
get much much better practical
efficiency yes Abby Abby was first
there's a student jao you soon the
audience at daybreak they saw him right
as a break worry yeah so they have he
has a follow-up work on our on his the w
in that paper he has a follow-up ok
great your one and right yes I don't
have another people following this paper
kawasaki Iran we actually mini mimic the
circuit of the top of the combo circuit
actually kind of smaller okay great so
after this okay great i don't know if
this paper is only print or not actually
I've never read this paper that I'm
talking about but good yeah they say
also you will see that they think they
can reduce it by a factor of three with
some simple optimizations that they
didn't do it okay good yeah I don't know
any there are two more people but I
forget who went they were who raised
their hand no okay so good so that's the
result and now so the rest of the talk
is technical details yeah circuits how
is it related to the two-party versus we
party so you are it's completing for
children or you don't know there's the
size of the circuit depend on the two
party versus three party yeah for sure
what do you mean yeah because what they
do is much simpler operations they do
like this fancy stuff so the rest of the
talk is like technical details how much
time do I have for me four minutes okay
so yes in Japan corruption why do they
use kappa circuits and not you know
informations ready so you know there's
some things they do are so i don't know
the real answers i don't know it's not
my paper but they do you some
information theoretic components but
then they all you know anyway they have
secret key stuff because they want to
establish some kind of channel and they
don't use randomness they use pseudo
randomness and stuff like that going on
but I don't have a really good answer
for you yes stash is available to answer
questions over email okay what
okay I'll let them know so this so I
guess this what happens here is a
description of the tree or AB of Shia
Val this is going back to the orem
setting no security for the client only
the server because then we want to do
this securely like each client said
whatever the client sends the server we
want to do it securely and efficiently
with three party computation so i'm
debating how in much detail to do it i
think you probably already know it and
maybe maybe many of you don't but i
don't know if in one minute you will
understand it in that case so let me
just say this the following so the way
this works the generally the tree or ram
is that let me do the whole picture okay
this is how it works the server stores a
bunch of trees okay and the client every
time completely downloads the first tree
which or this is the first 1i guess is
not a tree the first array which is not
too big it's a look up does it look up
it tells in some index of a leaf l1 he
sent it in the clear to the server the
server has some tree with leaf l1 and he
recovers the entire path from root to
the leaf the past the internal nodes are
buckets containing stuff and he sends
that entire path to the client the
client looks up in the path like the
prefix of the address he actually wants
to retrieve and that gives him another
pointer to another leaf in the next tree
which is bigger then he sends it in the
clear to the server the server sends the
entire path the client looks up the next
one and so on and only in the last tree
he gets the actual record encrypted
record that he wants and he decrypt it
and that's something with it so that's
that's roughly the trio ram and if you
were here in the boot camp in lane
described it in detail but the point is
all the client does is lookups ok so you
see it keeps looking at these ends and
look so n is what the client wants these
are this is the
dress is interested in it looks at a
chunk by chunk and for each one there's
look up for an address in the tree and
this is oblivious for the orem it's
secure against the server because the
server see is a bunch of leaves they
initially are assigned randomly and
there's another thing that depicted here
which is after you do it you like
reassign new random Leafs for every
location you insert everything back in
the root and then you do some kind of
eviction in order to of course make sure
the root and the entire tree doesn't
overflow okay so the clients called is a
sequence of array lookups okay this I
told him he sends me way too many slides
it's not my fault I cut down a bunch of
them trust me okay so good so what will
they do so the idea in three pc is this
the parties will share the entire thing
they'll show the the server stuff the
trees and also they will secret share
the location and the address that the
client wants will be shared among all of
them okay it's sorry not the party's p1
and p2 will share all of this and p3
will help and accommodate them by using
by helping them with correlated
randomness ok so hmm let me see so this
is how it's done so p1 and p2 want to
share this is the let's say this is in
1.41 tree for one look up the client or
you know the algorithm is interested in
n star and there's a lookup table for
each n what is the corresponding l and
this is secret shared in a standard XOR
like simple secret sharing way between
p1 and p2 ok and it's everything is
secret shared both the nstar that
they're interested in the secret jardin
two and one star X 0 and 2 star and also
the look-up tables everything is secret
shared and the goal is to send
information to p3 such that P 3 can
obtain the correct l that corresponds to
the end that is at X or of n 1 star nand
two star ok and because they have three
party it's easy for them to do it you
just know that instead of saying n 1
star X or n 2 star equals n 1i
XO and two I you can like shift stuff
around and see that N 1 star X 0 n1 I
should be equal to n 2 star X or into I
and so really which you can just name ai
and bi so really what's going on here is
the let me see this the string equality
problem and what they really want to do
is that this guy has a I L the prefix
here is a I the prefix here is bi and if
they are equal then they won't be free
to obtain the XOR of l1 and l2 and they
can do it efficiently I guess I don't
have time to explain how but very simply
what's on this slide is not exactly what
they do there's some complications this
is a hint to fix one complication this
is a hint to fix another complication
but it's not hard basically the whole
point is if p1 and p2 shared correlated
randomness they can easily send stuff to
p3 so that he can recover the right
thing the right Li lookup thing without
learning information okay so um yes okay
so that that's it really not counting
eviction so they also have some tricks
for eviction so this first explains
whatever I want to explain the eviction
yeah but let me say just one word about
the eviction in general whatever
optimizations you try to do for the
eviction you basically in two-party
computation it seems or at least they
claim to you have to do some secure
computation on the entire path including
its entire content okay whereas if you
have a third party the third party can
learn in the clear what the eviction
will be could learn like you know I
don't know the third bucket here should
move to the the first position and the
second bucket there or something like
that he can learn that logical thing in
the clear and then assist the two
parties and actually moving the data and
so it becomes better because it's like
corresponding to the length of the path
and not the size of the entire path with
the back end so they have a way to do
that too good that this was the point I
just make made and let me skip to the
conclusion he just sent it to me two
minutes before I got here but
nonetheless so the point is that they
did 3 party secured competition for Aram
seemingly faster than to party faster
than what we know so far ok this is the
so one thing I forgot to say sorry about
performance is that their performance
ends up very close to the original or
rammed the tree based or am performance
without so adding the secure computation
doesn't cost much at all ok so that was
an important point they have an
implementation which they will make open
source good so they have simple
improvements that will they think will
reduce this as two times faster he told
me thinks it will be three times fast is
simple improvements that they haven't
implemented yet and there's a bunch of
open problems of how to do things better
and faster one of them is the problem
that Raffy mentioned before here the old
Logan there's a bunch of open problems
and leave them here so you can look at
them that's it thanks yeah any questions
yeah something that I didn't get from
the odd you take your big data and you
are on it so you make it a little bigger
on to the den secret share it again and
make it twice as big ok that's a very
good question so what they do in this
present a I asked in the same question
what they do in this presentation they
do secret jarrett for two parties so one
party will be small and two parties will
be large in this presentation that's the
way it is what stash claims is that it's
very easy to make only one party large
and the other two parties small but I
don't know how to do that I like I mean
I didn't have time to talk to him about
it ok thank you again